hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 148 is it 148
148 I it turns out I'm Dr Brett
Weinstein and this is Dr Heather heying
and uh we are still functioning with
some temporary digs here I do want to
tell people
we are of course functioning with
temporary digs because we have moved and
that means we gave up our studio in
Portland we are erecting a new studio
however having moved to an island
compounds all of the labor shortage and
supply chain issues that exist on the
mainland and so it is detaining US
somewhat now here's the plan I think
you're really gonna dig it in the end we
are building the right Studio we are
building it well with an eye towards it
looking good and eliminating as many
technical hazards as can possibly be
eliminated but we know that finishing it
is a ways off so what we are going to do
is we are going to construct and we have
I already identified the location a
permanent temporary home for the Dark
Horse podcast
permanent temporary permanent temporary
home coming today from temporary
temporary yep we're going hopefully by
next week to permanent temporary which I
don't think is the right framing but
okay and at some point within the next
year we'll be at permanent permanent
um permanent temporary is a perfectly
good framing in light of the uh
standards of the moment I think it is
very descriptive why would we sync to
the standards at the moment because it's
funny I don't know
um
would you people expect more from us how
about temporary permanent that's better
that is better
all right well temporary permanent it is
uh we're going to be doing that and
hopefully I don't want to promise
anything because you never know what we
will discover in the process of getting
to our temporary permanent digs but uh
hopefully next week's broadcast will
come from there now I am curious and you
know it's always it's often a mistake to
say I'd like to know what people think
but um I have I've seen in in some
comments uh that have come my way that
people really like the homeier feel of
this and having the animals be able to
be on camera and such and the dog
snoring in the background is calming for
some people she's not starring yet
because we haven't yet put her to sleep
but we will I assure you
um but I am I'm interested to know what
people do and don't like that's not to
say that we're necessarily going to take
your your advice under consideration but
since we are in the design phase of the
permanent permanent Studio at this point
uh I'm I'm interested to hear what
people do and don't like you know do you
want to see us back in the sauna if you
want to see us in a but now what so this
is
um this is a this is a good Synergy you
want to know what people think and I
want to know if people think and if so
when people think now it's different
people in this case but um but anyway
yeah it would be good to know uh what
what people are hoping for and of course
what we will get back from such a prompt
is a total uninterpretable chaos
which we will try to meet everyone's uh
desires simultaneously nope that's not
who we are briefly we will consider
trying to nope satisfy everyone's
desires for a new set no
all right there's a little glimpse into
our relationship
live stream's the camera
yes and we will follow this live stream
with the Q a in fact last week uh we
followed uh by 22 and a half hours the
live stream with our private q a our
monthly private q a on my patreon it was
really even more fun this week this
month than it usually is like it was it
was great so those are still up we keep
those up and available for anyone who
joins my patreon at any time
um but the but I encourage you to join
the patreon uh to be able to ask
questions in advance and then they're
small enough that we actually engage
with the chat and can pick up new
questions as we go yeah it does strike
me as uh a if you want a more direct
less formal High Touch version of uh of
Dark Horse it does strike me we have an
awfully good time with those yeah yeah
we really do yep uh consider consider
all the usual things if you're watching
on YouTube consider watching on Odyssey
that's where the live chat is happening
right now we don't see it but um but
those who are on it do and are engaging
with one another uh we've got our book
being published in a few more languages
uh very soon a hunter-gatherer's guide
to the 21st century I continue to get
really interesting letters from people
every week about things they're learning
from it and
um I'm just excited by that
we have of course I write weekly at
Natural Selections on my sub stack uh
this week I wrote about woke hypocrisies
I'm going to talk a little bit about
that later in the show
uh
in which one of which followed actually
um I'd already written it in but it's
directly related to one of the questions
that we addressed in the private q a
last week which is to say why is it that
it is okay uh to effectively adopt a
woman face but it is not okay to adopt
blackface what is the distinction
between those two things so we'll talk I
ask that question as well in my in
Natural Selections this week and we'll
talk about it a bit uh later in the show
we have Zach if you want to show the um
the screenshot of the store so when we
are in our did we decide on temporary
permanent or permanent temporary I think
you decided that temporary permanent was
way better okay
now I can't remember which is which okay
a sticker perfectly equivalent they're
not though one of one of them one of
them modifies the other but I don't at
the moment I have now forgotten which
one I preferred which means it was not a
strong person I am so equally acceptable
okay so once we are in our temporary
permanent studio and also once we're in
a product permanent Studio we will have
a lot of things back again I will be
able to share my screen we will have
multiple cameras uh all of those good
things but for the moment I can't share
my screen and so here's Zach is showing
a screenshot of our uh fantastic store
as I mentioned last week it was uh
created and is managed by another couple
in business together and they do not
just the store the online management but
also they have the print shop uh which
is where they actually produce the
merchandise so high quality
um uh now I'm going to have this phrase
in my head for the rest of today so I
hope I don't keep saying it but like
high touch High touch environment I
apologize for that I was I was left
groping for words and I didn't want a
long unprofessional pause so I think it
I think it works basically if you know
if you ever have any trouble with an
order which is going to be very rare but
you'll get a you know a real person
who's awesome right here in the United
States helping you with that order and
as of last week we have a new a new
piece of merchandise which is our do not
affirm do not comply sure we still got
Keep Portland Weird as in Western
educated industrialized rich and
Democratic and several other products as
well we'll have another new product next
week which I think you guys are really
going to like so that is at
darkhorsestore.org check it out
and we are supported by you our audience
I've already mentioned my patreon Brett
had one of his patreon conversations
this morning how'd that go uh it went
beautifully I thought great uh we had a
couple OG game beers present which is
interesting
what's OG well I looked it up at one
point it's original Gangsta
um but lots of people who say oh gee I
think don't know that necessarily um
it's usually just original original
but oh gee
in any case
um
I just feel so out of touch but then I
you know even when I was 17 right right
we started out of touch which is I was
never paying that much attention to the
to that level of the
the cultural scene yep yep no I totally
agree with you anyway it was a great
conversation I thought
um we talked uh quite a bit about the
Oddity of this very particular moment
which we will get back to later in the
podcast but anyway yeah I thought it was
I thought it was great another
conversation tomorrow uh on uh more
evolutionary Focus awesome another
conversation on your patreon tomorrow
yep uh we encourage you to join join
those if you are so inspired and and
can't afford it
um we of course are still demonetized by
by YouTube because
um apparently all that uh
non-misinformation and
non-disinformation of which we were
accused of propagating a year and a half
ago now which most of which has now been
um well understood not to have been
missed or disinformation in the first
place
um has still not been recognized as such
by YouTube because I don't know they've
got like
fact Checkers running the thing as
opposed to scientists uh yeah fact heads
um
wanted to mention a couple more things
before we get to the uh oh right yep yes
um one
uh
I had a conversation with Bridget fedesy
which uh she and I both thought was
quite a good conversation uh eliminated
a lot of things I had slight trepidation
that releasing it into the world was
going to cause a uh a firestorm but why
oh because the topic is one that in my
experience typically
results in a catastrophe because people
immediately see that something that they
hold dear is in question and so there's
a defensive reaction that causes people
to fight back and sometimes quite
aggressively so just for those who
haven't yet run into your conversation
with her which was posted on Dark Horse
earlier this week it was following in
part on a piece that she published
called why I regret being a [ __ ] no I
think it was I regret wow I can't
remember I think it was just I regret
but nonetheless this was Bridget doing
uh something that she does marvelously
well she's very
um
open and ready to to look at herself and
reevaluate anyway so the conversation
started because that piece had had a big
effect in the world you and I had had
thoughts about it and anyway so we had a
conversation I strongly encourage people
to check it out
um and I think at the very least people
will find it provocative and there's
some stuff in there I think most people
will not have thought before and so
anyway worth a look
or just to listen yeah actually just to
listen would work too in fact uh I uh
because I'm uh when Zach is not here a
one-man operation uh I forgot to turn on
my camera at the beginning of the thing
so it's just Bridget for a little while
you can hear me uh and then I realize
that when I turned it on but well I mean
most
the vast majority of our audiences is
listeners only yeah so um so I think
they will be less disturbed by the
camera hiccup we so we know that and we
also know therefore that when we show
we also know therefore that when we show
images on camera that we have to explain
what it is because we see we see the
numbers and and those to be true yep
that's right
um the other thing was uh a conversation
that I had that was the result of a
discussion that you and I had on Dark
Horse a few weeks ago I had a
conversation with Robert Wright and my
conversation with Robert Wright is not
out yet it will be out shortly I think
people should definitely check it out
the topic more or less was uh am I nuts
are you nuts am I nuts
um you will be
pleased to know that he at least
nominally supported your interpretation
of uh his tweet just to let's go back
again for people who aren't paying quite
as close attention to this issue as as
you are we are uh he had posited uh
something that I read as this take of
Brett's is Bonkers and I've defended him
in the past but I'm not going to do so
here and you interpret it as this take
of Brett's is so Bonkers that I think
he's Bonkers and I'm not going to defend
him in general anymore he said well it
was ambiguous and he and I talked about
the ambiguity I just said those were the
two questions that we heard was I'm not
going to do that now which plausibly
means from now on or might mean just in
this instance he says it was just in
this instance and he says that uh that
that's clear because a earlier version
of the tweet that didn't quite fit in
the character limits spelled it out so
there's that nonetheless the
conversation we had actually reflected
the fact that this was no now his
General conclusion whether it was
insanity or not
um so the whole thing which I do think
people should listen to I think you will
find it very Illuminating
um has me considering the possibility
that I'm too nice and I should change
that
and
the reason I say that is that during
this thing he says some very pointed
stuff in fact he made a point I think he
came back to it twice do you want to
know the moment at which I stopped
taking you seriously that's fine you can
say that Robert
but at the end of the thing he wants to
invite me on camera to come continue the
conversation on his podcast
now why the [ __ ] would I do that having
allowed that uh he doesn't take you
seriously having specified exactly that
he doesn't take you seriously so my
sense is I should have said no why would
I do that and that should have been the
end of the discussion but instead
because I'm nice and arguably too nice I
uh didn't shut down that inquiry
immediately the way I should have so
anyway uh I would also be interested in
whether or not people think I'm too nice
I have a feeling we will get a mixed
message back on this one as well
um but anyway when that when that
podcast is out
yeah I guess I am yeah I guess I am
um I do suggest people check it out I I
thought it was
uh a fascinating interchange I thought
it well he will no doubt have a
different opinion but in my opinion it
revealed uh a kind of myopia that I
think is widespread and for which Robert
seems to speak so anyway uh check it out
and uh you know
agree or disagree all right all right
and if you're interested in having a
conversation uh with people who may
think differently from you but who are
not going to shut you down for thinking
differently from you you can find
conversations uh that meet those
criteria on our Discord server which you
can access um through joining either of
our patreons
and another way that we are uh making
our way in the world much to our
surprise uh is uh by having sponsors and
uh long-term viewers will remember uh
that when we the very first time that we
had that we ran an ad that we read on
our show which was something like May of
2021 I want to say something something
in there April March April May of 2021
we actually did a whole episode devoted
to what advertisements are we did a
bunch of pro bono ads including some
positive ones and some negative ones my
favorite was for Comcast
and apparently I antagonize people
because some people thought I was
actually promoting Comcast there whoa no
I was not
um but I you know and so that episode
and I didn't look I didn't remind myself
to go and figure out exactly what number
it was but uh struck us both as
potentially risky going down this
slippery slope of like we really
understand I think you have said in a
very pithy way that like advertising is
the the the Crux of the problem with a
lot of commercial anything commercial
media right that it is like as soon as
you have an incentive to please The
Advertiser then you risk sacrificing
editorial content and I of course talked
about a little bit the history in that
episode of how that has specifically
played out in women's magazines and how
Miz magazine for instance back in the
90s finally said no no more we're going
ad free because we are not going to
continue to change our editorial content
because you know Revlon say wants us to
have nice content next to their
advertisement for lipstick uh anyway all
of that said we only take sponsors uh
that make products or have Services uh
that we actually really stand by and
enjoy or in a couple of cases we have a
direct connection to someone who does
and in this case this week
um it's it's three things that we all we
all have direct connection to and uh
really really appreciate so if you are
in the uh the market for shoes a sofa or
some household goods that might even be
delivered to you on a regular basis
um consider checking out any of the
three sponsors for this week without
further Ado you're up first Brett all
right our first amazing sponsor this
week is Vivo Barefoot and I should say I
have stopped wearing Vivo barefoots
because I'm sitting on the sofa once I
am off the sofa I'm going to put them
back on because I really dig them what
you know you can get away with that with
Vivo Barefoot because we've actually had
a couple conversations with the guys and
they're going to give you a little slack
but you scared me there from her like
what are you wearing what are you doing
I mean we do have two actually two
awesome shoe sponsors and we recommend
both of them but Vivo Barefoot you
played any one time you should wear one
or the other yeah choose one of three
options Vivo or I'm not gonna name the
other one here because that's rude but
um or go barefoot all right
um
our first amazing sponsor this week is
Vivo Barefoot regular listeners will be
well familiar with Vivo by now but if
you're not you are in for a treat
seriously try these shoes most shoes are
made for someone's idea of what feet
should be vivos however are made by
people who actually know feet here at
Darkhorse we love these shoes they are
Beyond comfortable the tactile feedback
from the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot but modern shoes
that are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively affected foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis one in which people move
less than they might in part because
their shoes make their feet hurt
Vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
prevent to provide natural stability
thin to enable you to feel more and
flexible to help you build your natural
strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60 in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo Vivo
Barefoot is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop except for you except for me while
sitting on the couch and showering but
we can return to that in another episode
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear but not sitting on the
couch I actually they sent me a pair of
hiking boots and at first I was like
nope those aren't really my thing I've
got these great leather hiking boots
well I wore those out and I've started
wearing the Vivo hiking boots as well
they're great too they are but aren't
they leather I think they are yeah no I
mean I meant I had like I had one of the
traditional yeah I can't even remember
what all the brands are but I had one of
the traditional like heavy like super
expensive pair of like serious leather
hiking boots and uh and they wear out
because they will and I started wearing
the Vivo hiking boots and they're
actually so you had a set of hiking
boots from something that is not a
certified B Corp pioneering regenerative
business principle peoples their
Footwear is produced using sustainably
sourced material and recycled materials
with the aim to protect the natural
world so that you can run wild on it Dr
highing
go to Vivo barefoot.com Darkhorse to get
an exclusive offer 20 off additionally
all new customers get a 100 day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's Vivo barefoot.com
Darkhorse v i v o b a r e f o o t.com
slash Darkhorse
well you may not be wearing our first
sponsor this week but I currently am
wearing our second sponsor
okay not wearing so much but sitting on
it's all form a company that makes
terrific custom sofas and you can see
that right in the background here and we
are going to have in our permanent
temporary slash temporary permanent
studio uh yet another are our other
all-form sofa so you get to look at this
this beautiful sofa and consider for
yourself how you might like to have a
sofa in your own home for a while longer
on Dark Horse
um
and as nice as it looks feels even
better it's terrific for a fraction of
the cost of traditional sofas you can
customize size layout Fabric and color
they do armchairs and love seats all the
way up to an eight seat sectional this
is the easiest way to customize a sofa
and the quality is fantastic they're
beautiful and comfortable roomy and
adaptable all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home free and fast and
assembly is easy you say it's easy oh
yeah okay I did I paid I did not
participate in the Assembly of either of
the sofas or the disassembly and
reassembly of one of them into a new
configuration that's one of the most
amazing things about these I dare people
to look at what we've done and not think
hey that's versatile yeah super
versatile we turn to uh well we'll talk
about this next time we have an all
format when we're sitting on the
relevant sofa relevant sofa
it's what they should call it in whiskey
leather the relevant sofa in whiskey
leather we started with one beautiful
sectional relevant all-form sofa in
whiskey leather it's soft and supple and
warm unlike a lot of weather you've all
weather
yeah a lot of weather is not soft supple
or warm you'll grant me that especially
hail this is going to be silly this week
we'll get a late start we're going to be
here until dark yeah we all pile on it
to watch movies some evenings actually
we haven't done that since we've moved
since we don't really have a television
anymore
[Laughter]
it looks gorgeous and it's incredibly
inviting and comfortable a rare
combination some listeners have asked if
all form holds up to pets why yes it
does no
you can't necessarily tell from the fact
that they're on it
um that it still looks good despite that
they're on it the leather that all farm
uses and this is leather that we're
sitting on
is about 20 thicker than typical
Furniture leather and it shows nowhere
seriously there's no there's no animal
marks there's some fur on it at the
moment but you can't you can't ask them
to keep that off the
yeah okay
um it shows nowhere despite the fact
that both cats and the dog lie on the
couch a lot as you can tell
uh and if you prefer fabric all form
Fabrics are three and a half times more
durable than the industry standards for
heavy duty Fabrics so their Fabrics are
going to hold up really well with pets
as well we can't speak to that directly
but this is what we hear
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever to find your perfect
sofa check out allforum.com Darkhorse
that's all form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allforum.com Darkhorse step up your sofa
game today
finally we have public goods public
goods which I think was our very first
sponsor I think I may have that wrong is
a One-Stop shop for everyday essentials
their ingredients are carefully sourced
high quality and affordable and you can
simplify your life by getting your
Necessities at public goods public goods
has coffee and tea grains and oils like
Olive and avocado they have spices and
extracts vinegars and hot sauces
dishware and glassware there is so much
at public goods to make a meal including
the materials to serve it on and that's
not all they've got stationery and
laundry detergent Castile soap and trash
bags they even sell plants do you know
that I didn't know that yeah we have not
had any of their plants yet but they
sell plants uh they've got it all they
probably don't have it all but they come
close
public goods searches the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
Innovative products public goods cares
about health and sustainability their
products are largely free of harmful
ingredients and additives and the
ingredients are ethically sourced rather
than buying from a bunch of single
product Brands public goods members can
buy all of their premium Essentials in
one place with one beautiful simple
streamlined aesthetic and the
subscription service is efficient and
simple and easy to use public goods
members can buy all of their premium
Essentials in one place making it an
everything store for Dark Horse
listeners we have the following offer
receive 15 off your first public goods
offer with no minimum purchase they're
so confident that you absolutely love
their products and come back again and
again they are giving you 15 to spend on
your first product purchase regardless
of how much that purchase costs
go to publicgoods.com Darkhorse or use
code Darkhorse checkout that is
p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s.com forward slash
Darkhorse to receive 15 off your first
order
all right that's our ads
for that we know actually several things
here come together including from the
ads okay
um public goods when I look at a bottle
of let's say dish soap or something from
them right and it's
simple and elegant it is not trying to
call your attention I now realized
something I didn't realize before which
is that we are all stuck
with packaging designed to get you to
buy the thing in the store right when
the laundry detergent is shouting on the
Shelf to get your attention away from
the 12 other laundry detergent sitting
next to it right now arguably it's in an
arms race that it has to compete in or
it will go extinct but then
you're stuck with this thing shouting at
you from your you know laundry room
cabinet or your kitchen sink and you
know the thing is it's more it's more
you're tuning that out is more expensive
than you than you imagine yes the
attention economy is is important and
it's a little it's a little it seems a
little subtle at first but it's a little
bit like uh when we be in when we sort
of society-wide began to talk about
things like light pollution and then
sound pollution rather than just
particulate pollution that you're
inhaling in and we can more easily see
and measure the health effects on your
lungs of breathing in smog from say
1970s there in LA right but light
pollution has real harm sound pollution
has real harms
um not being able to get your attention
back and focus on whatever it is that
you are choosing to focus on uh also has
real harms yeah it's like a cognitive
pollution and you know the idea that the
packaging may be appropriate to you know
I don't think any of us like it but it
may be appropriate to selling the
product but the idea that you are going
to live with the externalized harm of
something that is designed to get you
not to think about other things uh you
know the price is higher than you think
until you start getting rid of that
stuff wasn't there there was a prick
line or a company there for a while that
was called something like ad free it was
specifically in just like beige
packaging with maybe simple black Sans
serif font lettering that was a little
bit like what public goods is now doing
but public goods you know is bigger it's
got the online presence but remember
some stores for a while there I don't
know maybe 90s early on so maybe it
still exists but you would see their
stuff and it and it did actually manage
to draw your attention if you had a
particular kind of mind anyway yeah on a
grocery store shelf say precisely
because it was it was sort of you know
expanses of like brown paper bag color
with simple black again Sans serif font
on it as opposed to you know tied
screaming at you in four different
bright orange and red colors yeah I mean
and and you know we've seen very clever
anti-advertising advertising like do you
remember when uh Dove started to reveal
what was done to these models in order
to make them you know sexy to sell
whatever product it was and you see how
much of this is you two can get skin
like this if only you have a
professional photo Shopper a
photoshopper and a team of you know
Cosmetics experts and hairdressers and
you know so anyway I think the thing is
you know one thing that you and I have
learned again and again is that because
of this world in which everything is
competitive and therefore there's an
arms race it leads to a world in which
there's very little that's actually
authentic and so
sometimes authentic is exactly what
people are starved for and so that can
be the feature it's also true I would
point out that uh
consider this exercise let's say you've
got two shampoos that are the same price
sitting on the Shelf at the at the
grocery store and one of them
has a famous spokesperson and you've
seen their ad on television or wherever
people see ads nowadays and the other
one you've only noticed on the shelf
right which should you buy well the
answer is you know that one of these
companies invested a lot in
merchandising the product that's
something that didn't go into the
ingredients of the product so it's
possible that the other one is just
taking home a lot more of the money
right but if they've both got about the
same percentage of profit they're making
on the product then the one without the
expensive spokes model put more into r d
is at least one possible interpretation
exactly and so in some sense a a wise
consumer would actually uh have a
penalty for the degree of reach that is
accessed by The Advertiser
um because that is stuff that didn't go
into the product yeah and you know that
the profit is you know whatever they
spent on Advertising to reach you their
profit is somewhere above that and you
know the more of these things uh the
more expenses you have the less went
into whatever it actually is yep
all right which brings us to this
odd present moment am I wrong all right
May I mean we're here yes well that's
true I guess if we're going to be
literal pet ants then yes what we just
said brought us to this place where we
haven't yet said anything so that's good
here we are did its job not saying
anything uh did you want to start by
talking about the election
yeah and actually I have two topics
um the election is one of them and they
do sort of fit under the rubric of this
moment and you know in some sense we
always talk about this moment but I mean
something very much narrower
um
I think on two fronts we are looking at
a version of
you know the chaos we've all become
familiar with that is novel
and one of them has to do with the
election and the other has to do with
what's going on at Twitter
and so anyway how these things fit
together is a little bit unclear but
let's start with the election one okay
here's the predicament I see
the
blue team
has
botched the job and the public is not in
the dark about this there's a job being
the job that they are supposedly
supposed to be doing once having
attained office or the job of the
election
the job in office and I would say that
our two major parties in the U.S are
foreign
about that folks
um we have an intruder at the door and
the dog is protecting us now the
Intruder is Toby
so maybe not as serious as the dog
thought at first but
um
all right the temporary permanence uh
set will be exactly as half-assed oh
we're just no I thought we were going to
Bar Toby so that the dog wouldn't fall
um
both parties are deeply corrupt
okay we have a two-party influence
peddling racket in which they win and
lose power trade off against each other
but nobody's representing the public and
hasn't been for quite some time I I take
the date back to uh the Clinton
Administration
um but we have two deeply corrupt
parties that said
there is a degree to which the public
having no better choice tolerates
very low quality governance
for fear of the unknown for fear of
electing the greater evil as you pursue
some alternative to the duopoly whatever
it may be
in this case
the blue team has botched the
governing process not just at the usual
level that corruption would typically
bring you to but at a spectacular level
right things in and around covid have
caused a failure that has created a
level of anger
um
that is not
it's not familiar from recent history
the problem is
the blue team is in this predicament
sorry the blue team is nothing to laugh
about Heather
we just we got we got chaos we got a
labrador who thinks she's a Chihuahua
and can walk through cameras and tripods
without disrupting I think she's working
she does not the blue team does not want
me exploring this and I think she's
working for him she is that is a
terrible thing to say you think our dog
is working for the Democrats I mean look
all they would need I think that would
be the worst thing you've ever said it
may be the worst thing I've ever well
all right this experiment with being
like you're too nice
I was trying it out
okay okay
my point is this and I'm I'm being
delicate here for what reason I don't
exactly know I guess because I know what
accusations will
uh come back at me if I just simply
spell it out but here's the problem
let's say that the election brings about
a substantial Red Wave sufficient to
switch both houses of Congress in the
red team Direction
well the red team which again I regard
is deeply corrupt the red team
uh would have the power
to
essentially get to the bottom of or near
the bottom of whatever has taken place
under the uh the The Blue Team structure
you're talking about like with regard to
coven
well I you know as you know I think
covid diagnoses the system it reveals
the depth of corruption and that the
the anger over
vaccine Adverse Events uh over uh
mandates and terrible Public Health
guidance lockdowns old people dying
alone all of these things rightly have
the public very very angry
with the blue team in control of all the
properties don't forget education about
schooling remote schooling masking of
children all of these things
the blue team at the moment today has
the power to fend off a real
investigation
it might lose that on Tuesday
if it loses that on Tuesday
I don't know what happens it's possible
that the network of corruption that
links the two parties is sufficient to
manage this so that we what we get is a
half-hearted investigation of what took
place or it is possible that the red
team will properly understand where it
is and it will actually resort to govern
and if it resorts
well I think this is I think this is
actually a tough question because when
you're when your job is influence
pedaling and then suddenly you're thrust
into the role of governing in a moment
where influence peddling wouldn't be a
good idea from the point of view of you
hanging on to power that actually
governing is the best thing you can do
from the point of view of hanging on to
power
um it's not clear what happens and so
the you know what I'm imagining is that
we could have a serious Congressional
hearings and that those things let's say
for example what happens if we start
uh investigating what the
interrelationship is between
pharmacizor
and our Public Health apparatus how it
is that
um such terrible products found
themselves mandated by a government that
should have known better if we start to
pursue that in earnest
there's really no telling where it leads
now it may be that we wouldn't have
gotten here if the things that have
everything to lose in that process
didn't have some sort of control
mechanism that could Stave off
that um that outcome but nonetheless
what I'm trying to say is
based on what we know and we are
Outsiders so we don't know much but
based on what we know
The Blue Team
is facing an election that
doesn't seem to me that it can
win or even that it can
control its losses to the point that we
don't end up in territory that would be
very dangerous for the blue team
so it can't afford to lose
you can't win
and
I don't know that it could I don't know
that it could cheat and
in that predicament it's very hard to
say what one expects and I know that you
know people I mean
both both teams cheat
we know this both teams cheat and it's
become more possible
since voting has gone kind of gone the
way of Education during covid which is
to say remote and asynchronous
where you know when we started voting
uh it went
you had to apply to get an absentee
ballot you had to have a reason to have
an absentee ballot and otherwise you
went to the to the polling place on
Election Day and you saw some of your
neighbors many of whom you may not
otherwise know and you stood in line and
you went to a little booth and it wasn't
all that secure and it wasn't really
private there's a little you know
hanging curtain between you and you know
the other four or eight or 20 or 300
people depending on the size of your
polling place voting at the same time uh
but and you got handed and I voted
sticker on your way out
but it felt
it felt meaningful in part because you
knew that there was going to be a space
and a time at which you were going to
vote after which you had voted
and presumably a large number of
Americans who are going to vote in this
election have already voted
and that changes the entire landscape of
you know what you know what what when is
it an October surprise is not November
the concept of an October Surprise by
which one of the major parties or both
of them will drop something into the the
public view in the last couple of weeks
before the election and thus change how
people perceive one of the candidates or
one of the big issues and thus you know
change history
that's that's not really a possibility
in the same way anymore and that's good
I think actually because that that
particular kind of manipulation is no
longer on the table but the lack of
synchronicity in both space and time for
voters now means that the whole thing is
more abstract for us and I mean I think
just as I think and I'm not positive
with this but I think I think that my
opinion right now is that just as remote
and asynchronous school it was bad for
children remote and asynchronous voting
is bad for democracy okay a couple
things we have to come back to from from
what you've just said here one you've
said
uh everybody cheats
both sides cheat okay now this is a
claim that we have to deal with with
Extreme Caution I believe that the
following thing is true
people who are partisans of either team
fervently believe the other team cheats
right
that's not the same thing as both teams
cheating but I will say
I think over a long time scale this is
the case and I have two pieces I know
that every individual does right but
that if you've got a party that's big
across time and space again that there
will be cheating within that party well
there's various different kinds of
cheating there's cheating within the
rules and there's cheating outside of
the rules okay both sides cheat within
the rules yeah how is it cheating within
the rules well let me give you an
example from my own personal experience
okay when I was a student at Penn in
1987 88 mm-hmm
um maybe seven eight eighty nine nope
I found myself so it must have been 80
88.
I found myself unable to vote though
registered to vote and the reason that I
was unable to vote was that Republicans
had a trick that they played in
Philadelphia and the trick was to
there was some sort of check algorithm
that you could trigger for a voter does
this person still live at this address
students overwhelmingly Democrats
students overwhelmingly move year to
year and they don't change their voter
registration because they're voting in
the same place and so it can be claimed
we're just trying to reduce voter fraud
we don't want someone voting twice
uh-huh right yeah and so instead you end
up getting to vote
none none right and I actually had a an
extraordinary conversation
I the president of the college did you
like go to vote and you're like I went
to vote and I found myself not
registered to vote because my address
was increased unregistered I had been
unregistered and I'd moved literally two
blocks from where I had been from The
Freshman residents to yourself so it
hadn't occurred to me to re-register
because my polling place was going to be
the same so what would be the point
great right
and I caught up to the president of the
college President of Penn yeah okay he
was walking down the street
of course you did
and I went up to him of course you did
well I was I was pissed off because I
think this was even the college
Republicans who had done it so this was
like you know this was like Friendly
Fire Within the college yeah within the
university I mean it wasn't friendly but
nonetheless I went up to University you
say college it makes it sound tiny yeah
well I went up to him and I was like sir
do you know that this is going on and I
explained to him what had happened and
he was like of course it's going on grow
up huh
seriously I don't think he actually said
grow up but that was certainly the
message that he delivered and you know
message received got it grew up I grew
up it was a relatively inexpensive
lesson but you didn't get to vote in
your first president presidential
election I can't remember there may have
been one of these things where there was
a contingency way where you could vote
and then you could pursue it and your
address could be reconciled and then if
the vote came down to a close thing then
it could be counted it was something
like that so I did vote but it
definitely was a trick but it was a
trick within the rules
nobody did anything illegal right
um but okay does the red team cheat in
elections well
I don't know if it's cheated in recent
elections I do know that during the bush
years the shenanigans that went on
surrounding die bolt push one or bush
two Bush two so like beginning with the
gore Bush collection and this is murky
because that's a fair fair piece of
History ago at this point but my
recollection is the following thing
there was all kinds of demonstrated
Shenanigans with voting machines which
were new at the time
um where they could be observed to be
switching votes and I was like oh these
things are computers they're complex you
know who knows what's you know but it
was like oh they do seem to do this in
One Direction and not the other and
what's more die bold seems to be a
partisan Corporation deeply in bed with
the Bush Administration and then there
was the craziest piece of evidence at
all but from my perspective
made it a relatively open and shut case
which was
those of us who were very interested in
election Integrity knew that the key to
election integrity was a paper record of
each vote so that you could if a
voting machine this was back when we
people were still going to the polls
absentee ballots was still rare but
you'd go and then you'd be on a machine
but like no I actually need a receipt
right and I forget what the name for the
receipt is but something a paper record
that reflects how you voted so that you
could look oh that's not how I voted
something's wrong with this machine or
that is how I voted and then we can
check the receipts against the
um the machine uh tally and see that the
machine is [ __ ] up and here was the
crazy thing the answer was well we can't
do that
because the
printer apparatus then makes the
machines unreliable oh does it
this from diebold which made its money
making ATMs
right oh oh right oh and so my point was
oh
got it right this was like oh you want
to vote do you grow up you know so
all right so that was good stories man
to my way of thinking pretty strong
evidence that our elections had lost
their integrity back then so anyway for
those of you who will challenge us and
say you know you know I know what you'll
say you'll say conspiracy theory this
that and the other the answer is well no
I think I think the smart the the clever
but dismissive response will be we're
talking 1988 and 2000 it's now 2022 and
uh the valence on Who's Cheating has
changed oh sure but
I will say this the key thing and you
come close to it in talking about the
difference between how we used to vote
and how we vote now and the absentee
ballot thing and that they're a big deal
the biggest problem
with a huge fraction of the populist
voting absentee
is that it has eliminated
it has not completely eliminated exit
polling because you can still pull
people on the exit but most of the
people who vote aren't there and it is
non-random who votes from home so to the
extent that people with a particular
political bent may also have a
particular bent towards either voting in
person or voting at home what the exit
pollster gathers does not necessarily
predict the election so right all of
this is to say
there is a tremendous focus on
getting people to vote
that focus is usually partisan and the
idea is
we need more of our people to vote and
presumably we need less of their people
to vote but the most important thing
from the perspective of election
Integrity is not the number of people
who vote
right as long as the people who vote are
representative it doesn't change the
outcome except very rarely by noise
factors the most important thing is the
Integrity of that vote and our ability
to check it
and so the idea that convenience of the
voter right or you know whatever the
arguments are in favor of absentee
voting they suck compared to what we
gave up which is the ability to know
when our election has been stolen which
requires you know a paper trail uh exit
pollsters and you know sophisticated
nonpartisan people to be able to deal
with the factors like people's
embarrassment of voting for a certain
party which causes the exit pollsters
not to have a great
a high resolution count those things are
all real but the point is
something has produced a mechanism of
voting
that now we can't even check right and
it's like everything else where the idea
is you know oh well let's
80 effective you know why wouldn't you
take it's 80 effective and it's safe
well
can I see the paper and
more importantly I can see the paper but
can I see the data that generated that
paper nope you can't yeah right
um so that's that's kind of where we are
is we have an election with a huge
amount riding on it because the amount
that the blue team has to lose in the
outcome of this election is spectacular
like even to the point I'm not saying I
expect it but even to the point of
people who have played a prominent role
um facing criminal penalties well I
wonder if this doesn't actually
partially explain uh the increasingly
Infamous piece that came out in the
Atlantic this week
uh written by Emily Oster uh asking for
amnesty
um not even asking for forgiveness and
not apologizing
but asking for amnesty for those who got
it so wrong
and during coven and it does seem to me
that that is exactly what many on team
blue in power especially in the public
health apparatus you know that racket
did a tremendous amount of damage to
people killed people damaged people
broke up families destroyed income
streams made the last moments of lives
for people
um bereft of meaning and alone and the
idea that you would ask for amnesty
without yet recognizing the errors and
without yet fixing them and without even
an apology
is remarkable and it will work for some
but it will work mostly for those who
were kind of on the fence and we're kind
of maybe feeling a little bit bad but
didn't really do that much and for the
most part those who have been clear-eyed
and seen it or who've been the at the in
the brunt in the you know in the
the focus of some of the the hatred and
the actual misinformation or the actual
disinformation
um what what that article
saw coming back at it what the author
Oster did presumably and went the
Atlantic the publication didn't know the
Atlantic and publication that I once
loved
saw coming back at it was
in no small part anger and it is
Justified anger and so you know what
what this election in part is standing
for legitimately what you were saying is
actually this is really important
because while we don't expect either
party to be interested in actually
governing as insane a sentiment as that
is it is possible that at this moment if
there is a turnover in power that that
team red would actually choose to govern
because they can see because it would be
clear that that was about a deep
frustration and that is underselling at
tremendously a deep frustration on the
part of the populace who have been
gaslit and damaged and lied to and told
to just suck it up and forgive and like
no it's like we're gonna need a lot more
before that is going to happen we're
going to need a lot more I do think
the amnesty discussion as much as uh
uh it was a unbelievably audacious uh an
asinine request really especially Camp
coming from where it did emerge from
yeah we have two tiers right there are
people who made serious errors
interpersonal errors and those people
need to own up and yes we need to accept
them back into our lives and that would
be a bit painful but amnesty has a role
here and frankly if you're higher up
um we
ought to think very carefully I think
we're talking about I'm sorry but when
you're talking about individuals in your
family and many people many people
really do feel I think legitimate like
I'm so hurt and I'm so betrayed and I
missed the important moments and I was
forbidden from attending you know
Christmas and birthdays and all of these
things and
I will forgive and I will move on with
my family but that's not amnesty right
amnesty is a bigger societal level thing
so that's not amnesty that's forgiveness
I agree and forgiveness yes when you
know when when warranted and I want to
point out uh it was a a minister in
Canada we may have even talked about
this I'm not sure there's a piece of
video that circulated a couple weeks ago
in which a minister in Canada was
confronted over the fact of the firing
of a state employee for not complying
with the vaccine mandates and you're not
talking about a religious person you're
talking about the head of state of
Alberta yeah yeah correct yeah I don't
remember her name but the newly elected
head of state of Alberta and I don't
remember if I don't think she's called a
prime minister but maybe but the newly
elected head of state of Alberta when
asked on stage and you know what you
know when do you think that we might
begin to see apologies and reversals of
mandates and stuff she says I will
apologize right now she said right now
and then and then she goes on to say and
I will do what's in my power to get you
rehired if you wish to rejoin us and my
feeling is that is exactly the behavior
that we have to have somebody
recognizing their own error owning up to
it doing what they can it wasn't her
error though
the error of her government which she
has just obtained a position of power in
which she can do something about it this
this was not her saying I was wrong
because I don't think she had been wrong
well I if that's true it changes it a
little bit but nonetheless it is the
behavior we should want if she didn't do
anything wrong and she's apologizing for
others it's a little
it's it's different it's more in the
realm of reparations but I do think that
that's the city yeah more in the realm
of reparations is a good way to put it
right apologizing for a historic wrong
um but but she was elected on this wave
of anger and frustration and with the
hope that she might do something about
it and so she is and so she did and not
just apologize but attempt to repair so
that's that's what we want
um and there's a lot of room you know
there's a lot of room for repair that
comes from an airing of the full
totality of what happened and how it
worked and everything we could learn
because the key thing is to discover
what happened so that this can't happen
again not only on this topic but any
topic because the real story here is the
complete Corruption of the system that
allowed this to go down the way it did
right that corruption is a threat era if
covid vanished tomorrow that corruption
doesn't get any safer
um the other thing I wanted to point out
though is
the possible shift to Red Power
that would come Tuesday raises a real
question so I have said and I think I
was too aggressive in saying
both parties are seriously corrupt
period they are but there's a question
about how that works right and my
contention has always been in the
context of game being other things
you have a population inhabiting a
corrupt system and everybody in that
population almost without exception
exhibits corruption it is wrong to
assume that that is because they are
fundamentally corrupt because there's no
other way to be in this system and so
the question is if freed from an
obligation to be corrupt
what do you do some of them will remain
corrupt because it's fundamentally what
they are some of them will switch gears
immediately because they'd much prefer
not to be corrupt and a lot of them will
weather vane and they will go whichever
way the winds are blowing but it is a
mistake to write off everybody who is
corrupt inside of a corrupt system as if
it's written into their DNA because it
isn't so one thing to hope for is that
if the red team
routes The Blue Team on Tuesday
that actually the opportunity to govern
in the interest of the public
will be enticing to many in that party
and in sort of if I can use the analogy
are there any Patriots left in politics
right and there are some but
remember after 9 11.
you had a bunch of phony journalists who
did phony [ __ ] journalism every day
that they were working before 9 11.
suddenly 9 11 happens
advertisements disappear from the
airwaves for a couple of weeks I think
and you've suddenly got a bunch of
people who are dressed as journalists
standing in front of high quality
cameras that a journalist might stand in
front of being expected to deliver a
news story and lo and behold a bunch of
these people who were basically faking
being journalists
started doing journalism
right and it lasted for a little while
it was a very different environment
right you had actual people reporting on
an actual story we were all paying
attention it was like a totally it was
like a moment that exists isolated from
all the surrounding moments and it's
like okay there's yeah potemka
journalism and you take away the facade
it's like oh wait you but you look just
like you're actually doing the thing
right like why okay you could have been
doing the thing all along then right
like that could have been happening
right yeah but here you are you got the
microphone go right so anyway let's
let's imagine for a second that you've
got a bunch of people you know you've
got these you know beautiful Halls of
Congress where you could in fact do
governance right we don't do it that way
we do have the facilities we've got the
facilities they're lovely you know right
um
so austere you know and it's not foam
marble either it's actual Marble Marble
so yeah anyway I would love to see an
outbreak of governance uh and you know
it could spread like a pandemic across
all three branches would that be
something dude yeah I'm not I'm not I'm
not signing on with that you're not no
but an outbreak of governance that that
I'm into all right outbreak of
governance we can we can uh we can hope
for that yeah so all right which brings
me to the second part of this
uh oh yeah yeah
the second part of this is that all
right this election snuck up on me a
little bit I'm used to
rolling my I mean you know the offerings
are oh
it's because I have not really been a
believer in
uh
changing things through elections for
decades right like you would need a
Unity
2020 style plan to make something useful
enough you can elect a hopeful person
but the system is so corrupt and so
overwhelming that you know real change
doesn't come from this mechanism even
though it should right
um so this snuck up on me because in a
sense the actual possibility of this
kicking us into a governance mode didn't
occur to me until late that's on me
um
but the other part of this puzzle is
something Darkhorse viewers and
listeners will be well familiar with
which is the idea that zero is a special
number and that what's going on with
Elon Musk and Twitter is a potentially
decisive battle I think most people
outside of the zero is a special number
of conversation don't really understand
they may think it's very good but they
don't understand that actually this
could be the object on which our
predicament pivots and that for that
reason
it is much more important than its
percentage of the conversation would
suggest right that a
Elon is probably
in more danger than you would ordinarily
expect over a business play like this
fiduciary danger every kind of Danger
let's put it this way if if I'm right
about the zero is a special number thing
then the ability to generate a platform
in which Free Speech actually rains and
he figures out how to police the correct
boundaries of that where you deal with
the stuff that's illegal maybe you deal
with certain kinds of content that don't
belong on Twitter
right but that by and large people are
allowed to express ideas offensive or
not wrong right doesn't matter we are
allowed to Hash these things out
um the way the founders intended
if he does that we live in a different
world right that's the zero is a special
number argument we live in a different
world if that happens therefore the
things that cannot survive in that world
are going to take up arms against it in
all kinds of forms and we've seen some
of this already
um Zach do you want to put up uh that
tweet
um so there's here's this is a tweet
from Elon Musk in which he reveals that
uh you're able to read it from there
Heather yeah but can they hear you okay
uh Twitter has had a massive drop in
Revenue due to activist groups
pressuring advertisers even though
nothing has changed with content
moderation and we did everything we
could to appease the activists
uh extremely messed up they're trying to
destroy free speech in America and this
is from I can't see the date November
what's fourth I guess this is from
yesterday yeah as we're talking
um well I have not seen this tweet
before and the thing that jumps out to
me there is we did everything we could
to appease of course and uh one of our
friends I can't remember who uh
responded uh you mustn't do that there's
nothing you could do that will possibly
satisfy them and Elon responded you're
right yeah but anyway yeah it's an odd
choice of words on his part we don't
really know what he means uh when he
talks about the degree to which this is
affected Revenue but but the point is
this
and this is uh and who who's dropped out
actually you you just mentioned the
story to me right before we came on air
so what prominent among the those who
are
uh the euphemism is pausing their
advertisements on Twitter pausing are
they include Pfizer General Mills and
Audi now I don't know what to make of
Audi obviously Audi including yeah Audi
is Volkswagen yeah and and Porsche right
yeah I think so yeah
um and they obviously have
a close call with uh the corporate Grim
Reaper recently over the uh the
Shenanigans with emissions right where
they were gaming the emissions
tests oh that's right was and it was
that was Volkswagen yeah yeah now I will
say it's not obvious two years back it
is a few years back and it's not obvious
to me that that would motivate them to
engage in this but who knows what else
how else it's not obvious to me why
they're on this list but yeah who knows
well in General Mills is huge General
right General Mills is huge but
let's let's talk about pretty big too
let's talk about Pfizer first because
Pfizer
is pretty clear what's going on oh
Pfizer cannot survive in a world in
which we are able to fully explore what
has taken place their business model now
depends on speech being intensely
limited and I'll give you an example
Zach do you want to put the other tweet
up
that flies everyone yeah
so in this tweet
so isn't that smaller enough that I
can't this is this is a interchange the
Tweet has a video on it which we can't
show you unfortunately who's tweeting it
who's it from Dr Ellie David
I don't know who that is yellow Eli Dr
Eli David but the point is it is a it is
a interchange between borla and uh some
reporter some interviewer and in this
thing this is a new it's a interesting I
can't see it but also everyone just
listening can't see it either all right
unfortunately our setup here does not
allow me to read it and I don't remember
it precisely
yeah or if I could see it okay uh Pfizer
CEO the efficacy of our vaccine in
children is 80 percent
reporter are you talking about efficacy
to prevent severe disease or to prevent
infection
advisor CEO to prevent infection
need more evidence of fraud
so that need more evidence of fraud is
editorial that's Dr David yeah so the
point is here
like when is the tweet and when is this
interchange uh
nonetheless we are talking about the
efficacy in children so we're talking
about
recent history this is after we know
that Pfizer already uh
was aware that blocking transmission was
not
um
was not a feature of their vaccine
so the point is you have in modern times
you have a misrepresentation of this
product by the CEO
now that is arguably fraud
here's the point
if it is fraud and if that is proven it
eliminates their immunity from liability
does it yes and so the immunity from
life I don't know the legal steps well
enough but I guess I'm surprised if that
is true breaches uh it breaches the
contract if the CEO says something but
he knows to be untrue that's a breach of
contract no no if he misrepresents
knowingly misrepresent engages in fraud
surrounding the products as it does
something that it doesn't do and he
knows it that's fraud it breaches the
contract his immunity their immunity
evaporates so my point would be you have
an unprecedented level of Adverse Events
we see this captured in the very system
the European yellow card system we see
it in the military system tremendous
number of people have a claim that is
apparently worthless in light of the
immunity that Pfizer has but is restored
if Pfizer no longer has that immunity so
that which rests on this election and
Elon musk's ability to stabilize a free
speech environment at Twitter is
tremendous not surprising to see Pfizer
engage in spite blocking itself from
access to potential customers right it
was advertising on Twitter it's decided
hey we don't really want those customers
and it has a [ __ ] explanation of why
right oh it doesn't seem like a good
environment for us to advertise bull
right your customers are still there so
why is it doing this because it can't
survive in that world
it is trying to block it's trying to
keep us at zero right because zero is a
special number and
in essence what I would argue is you're
going to have all of these forces
that can't live in that world that are
going to take up arms against what musk
appears to be trying to do
which also means that the importance of
him succeeding and our ability to help
him succeed
in spite of these forces uh is very much
a Live question
and I want to point to just a couple
more things one do we yeah
um
famously Elon has proposed a eight
dollar a month charge for verification
at Twitter
didn't he propose a 20 a month charge
and watched and waited and then at the
point that he proposed an eight dollar a
month charge a lot of people who were
who were going to be objecting were like
oh that's a relief that's part of what
happened is it I don't know that it may
be it's hard for me to imagine that
maybe I was away but you did that okay
in any case yeah here's here's what I
that was low level but I was Savvy that
was that was smart it is smart
um the number of dollars doesn't really
matter
I want to point out a couple things
a as somebody who has used Twitter
without thinking about paying for it
since 2009
um
there is it well doesn't I mean the idea
isn't that you have to pay to use
Twitter but if you want a a blue check
mark you have to pay a monthly yeah but
we'll we'll get there to me the answer
is oh if Twitter blue check mark costs
eight dollars a month then either you
don't want to be on Twitter or you want
to pay the eight dollars a month
there's no argument that I can see for
any serious person not paying that
charge walking away I could see it
and here's the reason
first of all just so that our audience
knows the score here
um you and I are approximately equally
terrible
I have a blue check mark no I mean I'm
not going to say which
language yeah our son does not think
asymmetrically asymmetrically terrible
and is not coughing up the info it's a
two-tailed claim on his party yeah he's
not gonna go one he's not going to
reveal which direction okay things
things suddenly got real yeah
but oh after the podcast all right
um
in any case the but let me we can fast
forward this like you've been on Twitter
since 2009 apparently yeah right um you
ran a foul yet again of some insane mob
by speaking truth and not stepping down
when they made outrageous claims about
you you've done it before you've done it
since you did it famously on May 23 2017
in a class or in a hallway at Evergreen
9 30 in the morning at 9 30 in the
morning and
um suddenly your Twitter account which
had
400 and something followers right and
you'd been pretty active like you you
did social media a lot
um I had walked away from here I had
tried it for a while and it was like
tweeting into a void and so I'd walked
away okay but you you went up to like I
don't even know 17 000 or something I
think it was within a week I think I
think it was a couple of hours of
magnitude like you know it wasn't quite
twenty thousand but some something
between 10 and 20 000 in about a week
and about a week and a half after that
at the point that it's clear that our
world is never going back together yeah
in the same way it was I said to you
having issued social media completely
having said I will never I do not I
shall not said to you I guess I'm gonna
have to get on Twitter aren't I yeah um
and so opened up a Twitter account on
June 1st of 2017. right
um but I wasn't in the public eye I had
no experience with social media all of
this you because of what happened and
because you were in the Limelight you
very quickly got verified well and I was
almost so before you're like oh you know
basically only terrible like there's a
reason that I I was speaking morally we
were equivalently terrible
um the asymmetry in our Twitter accounts
early on
and so I and my so you got blue you got
verified and I then applied after I had
a New York Times in a Washington after I
had a Washington Post op-ed that that
went big and they said uh actually we're
stopping that for the moment and you
know it was like literally a week after
a friend of ours got Twitter verified
and ever since I've tried several times
and each time they're like yeah this is
what I want to get at right okay so
first of all uh a hat tip to Eric who is
the one who said you really need to get
verified so I got verified right away
otherwise I might have delayed and would
have also run a foul of whatever it is
that
so what Twitter did was it claimed to
have stopped the program
you could no longer apply to be verified
while it continued to verify people
which turned the check mark into exactly
what they swore it wasn't right it was
not supposed to be as Twitter sanction
it was supposed to be an indicator that
you were who you said you were right and
Heather has endured impersonators and
she has also become a best-selling New
York Times author and uh she how many
you've got
200 how many how many followers you have
on Twitter roughly oh about 200 000 200
000.
it was stuck at about 200 000 for close
to a year yeah actually we were both
throttled and then musk
um either as he was making the move or
or or just after he did
um it went up like ten thousand almost
overnight yeah it was a a muskox in a
china shop and anyway because this is
not very interesting right um but the
point is the point is that program uh
became an arbitrary nightmare yes uh in
between my getting verified and you're
attempting to and being rejected and
lots of other people who should have
been verified to have been rejected and
then lots of nonsense little tiny
accounts even CCP shills have been
verified it's a nightmare yeah but what
those who do not have a check probably
in general do not know is that it
changes your experience of Twitter and
the reason
is because there are hidden features
inside the app that only trigger if you
have that so if everyone can buy access
then that's going to be less meaningful
no hold on it's you still have to be
there you have to be verified so it you
cannot verify an arbitrary number of
accounts if you would like to be
verified as who you say you are you will
be able to pay bucks a month and get a
verification I see now here's the reason
that this matter is tremendously okay
there are two reasons actually one of
them
is that you know musk has been very
focused on Bots
I don't know why he's focused on Bots
and he's not focused on sock puppets
okay there are more Bots they're cheaper
but they're also way Dumber right right
we know that the sock puppet thing is
real the Navy had a program in which
they had literal software that allowed
one person to man many accounts blah
blah blah blah blah yeah Define the fox
puppet is an account manned by a human
it's not an artificial intelligence it's
a human but the human is there for a
purpose it's a
it's a account designed to steer
conversations right and so I get a lot
of these things that I don't think are
Bots and it's like oh you know we were
really big fans of yours and then you
went crazy and it just it's hard to
watch you you know your 15 minutes are
up what whatever the hell they say right
um and then you look at the at the
account and it's like oh they're
followed by 21 people they follow 517
people and they were registered in 2013.
what the what is that account that's a
weird account and then you look at what
they tweet and it makes it's incoherent
right I will say this is
it for people who read fiction uh who
are interested in an awesome story
um but also interested in this aspect of
modernity uh and I mentioned at another
point that I was reading
um the the latest in the Quran strike
detective series by Kenneth Galbraith
who's actually JK Rowling
um the ink black heart is uh
super giant book in which one of the
things she explores Rowling explores as
the author is exactly this and there are
you know they're turning out without
without giving anything away there turn
out to be multiple accounts that are
actually having been created by one
person who end up doing the work of
creating a sense of community a sense of
a movement where there isn't of movement
where there is a one disgruntled person
in some cases or you know a couple of
disgruntled people who can then you know
make it seem like there's more of them
and thus it's easier to make the
movement grow this is sort of like a
cheat on producing positive feedback
where you otherwise wouldn't get an in
yeah absolutely and it can work
constructively and it can work
destructively but it's a major force of
nature
on Twitter and elsewhere yeah so anyway
the point is inside of the app if you're
verified you have the ability to look at
only activity by other verified people
right and so if you're in the position
of having a very large account
you go from a completely noisy rendering
of the world full of bots and who knows
what else to a limited rendering where
you see only things from people that
Twitter has established are who they say
they are if you were to globalize that
program so the point is you can't have
multiple verified accounts because
you're only one person and you'll be
verified once then the point is suddenly
Twitter becomes the noise level drops
through the floor there'll still be
garbage there'll be haters but there
won't be armies of bots and sock puppets
and who knows what else so the point is
the difference between Twitter at eight
bucks a month and Twitter at free
is gargantuan potentially and the point
is if you want Twitter for free you'll
still get it but you'll get noisy
Twitter right you'll get dunked Twitter
Twitter you won't get intellectual
Twitter journalist Twitter scientist
Twitter right so anyway that's a big
deal if he can get this to happen it
does involve Shifting the revenue model
um for Twitter but that also has another
a collateral benefit
which is
um
many of us have noticed and I think uh
famously
um Zuckerberg may have said this
publicly
um if the product that you are enjoying
is free
you are the product right and what that
means is that you are getting the
product for free because what is really
being sold is your eyes and mind to
advertisers you are being sold to them
right
I think I think I object to the
universality of that statement I think I
think there is a lot of Truth in it and
we should all beware when we are going
around going like oh I can get this for
free give me more give me more and then
you know our attention is being sold and
our and then to return to that where we
started right it's our attention that's
being sold on the other hand uh just to
give an example that I know because it's
it's mine I give away almost all of the
content that I write on Natural
Selections because I want it to be
available to the widest audience
possible and the number of uh free
subscribers I have is 20 times the
number
uh yeah 20 times the number of paying
subscribers I have and I do put out
content for my paying subscribers else
you know why would anyone pay for
anything and obviously that is a
tremendous help uh with you know with
with us being able to live the lives and
maybe you know that we that we have here
and with all of our animals who are now
on screen and uh and and continue to do
the work that we're doing
um but the free content is not about
making my audience into the product
right at all look right so I just said
that like there's there's a there's a
truth there that is important and deep
and it is not a universal yeah let's say
there's some there's some threshold of
scale
um that is going to make this true
obviously
you know and I this is
this is a principle across many things
right I I argued in the uh the
discussion with Bridget fedesy that
there's a very there's a perfect way to
define porn unless you want to
instantiate the definition the way you
define it is uh that it is erotica done
for profit motive so I actually I
haven't listened to the whole episode
yet but I actually listened to part of
it this morning and heard that and I've
heard you say of course that definition
before and you know our books are still
um in boxes so I don't have access to it
else I would have found it and brought
it today but
you said that this is a great
theoretical definition that's going to
be hard to instantiate legally but I
think right away my mind went to a book
that I own that we own by Anais nin
um that I don't remember what it's
called
um but it's it's a book of erotica that
she wrote to pay her bills right well so
you have this and the question is would
she have written it anyway would she
have bothered to try to publish it you
don't know so all I'm arguing is the
fact that there are examples where you
get something for free and nobody's
selling your attention to somebody else
doesn't negate the principle that for
all intents and purposes when you are
talking about uh you know
broadcast media social media platforms
all of these things that are advertising
driven what's going on is your attention
is being sold to an Advertiser which is
why you're getting the thing for free
and I would also point out
um I think we've talked before about the
principle it's not the box it's the
business model but the difference
between Network TV driven by ads right
Network TV was mind-numbing right the
jokes weren't funny the sitcoms weren't
interesting it was nonsense
HBO charged you for Access and it didn't
have commercials and it was like oh now
we can do you know these uh you know
these we can do the equivalent of
serialized uh novels and things like
this suddenly the uh it's not that the
audience are morons it's the necessity
to keep you watching between commercial
breaks puts a whole different set of
constraints on the thing but anyway
point is
I don't love the idea of paying for
Twitter because I've gotten used to
getting it for free but when I think
about the two different twitters current
Twitter and future Twitter I'm excited
by this uh change and
I do think it's a very clever way to
solve the problem that currently
threatens Twitter which is that a lot of
the big players in the world of power
can't survive in a world where Twitter
works and so they're going to try to
pull the rug out from under it and I
would suggest
that the right thing to do as as we did
with Joe Rogan when he was being
threatened by all the nonsense you know
when they try to drive him from Spotify
and all of that
um the idea that Joe Rogan was doing a
huge service for the world and that we
needed to thank Joe Rogan and not
abandon him that wasn't key and at this
moment I would say there is no better
play on the map not even close to the
one that musk is engaged with at Twitter
do I know for sure that the guy's for
real I don't but again there's no better
play anywhere and the chances that he's
for real seem pretty high so
um I would suggest something like uh
#got your back that that ought to be the
mechanism by which we rally behind him
and stare down these advertisers that
want to kill off free Twitter because
they can't live in a world where we get
to talk
and when you say free Twitter there you
don't mean
yeah I don't mean financially free I
mean spiritually free
all right
um well it's we've been at it for a
while and we haven't gotten to most of
the things that we had been hoping to
talk about I'm not sure exactly how to
play this
um
maybe I can do a very quick job of what
I was going to do here on um Zach I sent
you a number of screenshots if you want
us was it they were numbered they're
numbered
but
they are numbered one two three four
five
so maybe we should skip this because I
have them here in my numbered order and
I don't know how to describe them to you
otherwise so why don't you go on with
what else you were going to talk about
all right
um
I wanted to talk briefly about this
question of the bivalent boosters
it occurred to me in thinking about them
that I had sort of accepted I mean
there's a tremendous Shenanigans being
played with the so-called evidence that
suggests that they are safe and the
evidence that they are effective
um
it is of course nonsense they use
proxies like uh the
amount of antibody reaction that is
stimulated being four times uh the
traditional one which doesn't say
anything about how effective it is
um but anyway I wanted to get to the
question it occurred to me that I had
accepted
the idea of a bivalent booster bivalent
means that it responds to two different
antigens
um one of them being the uh the OG covid
strain out of Wuhan the other being uh
Omicron
and what was the first the the original
Wuhan strain okay
um
and so okay all well and good as far as
that goes they've got a single
inoculation that triggers the production
it's an mRNA
that triggers the production of the
proteins from two different strains of
covid with the idea of alerting the
immune system to either one of them so
that it can respond
but the more I thought about it
it's not entirely clear bivalent does
not explain which version of bivalent
they are delivering and the particular
catastrophe that one predicts depends on
which of these mechanisms they are using
could be that they've taken two full
doses they've taken a Wuhan dose and a
Omicron dose and they've
put them together and they're giving you
effectively a double dose one of which
is
um targeted at a strain that is as far
as we know extinct in the wild it could
be
um
that they have linked these two things
together in a single mRNA transcript and
so you know a cell will take in both
messages and transcribe both proteins
from uh from one transcript it could be
that they have taken two transcripts and
they've mixed them together and you get
a half dose of each so this is I have
not looked into this but presumably
that's proprietary we don't know we
don't know what what they mean precisely
what the mechanism is to produce this
vaccine I called Robert Malone and asked
him because this is his area and he
knows it well what he believes is going
on is that these are two separate
transcripts being delivered at a half
dose each
and I wanted to put a little color on
what that implies so that's based on
what he
he doesn't have direct Insider
information but that is what he predicts
that is what he infers from what he has
seen okay
now
I had a particular concern about this
and he suggested another one which was
on my radar but probably not at a high
enough priority
my concern is this long time viewers
will have heard me describe the hazard
of this very poorly targeted vaccine a
vaccine
a so-called vaccine that is supposed to
have stayed locally
at the site of injection instead seems
to circulate around the body and has no
targeting mechanism whatsoever so that
it is taken up you randomly is probably
the wrong word stochastically it's
probably the wrong word haphazardly is
certainly a correct word which is to say
it is taken up by the cells that it
encounters that have a high affinity for
the lipid nanoparticles and those aren't
in any way good cells inherently to be
transcribing this protein in fact
haphazard from unique initial conditions
um based on point of entry and the
degree to which there is aspiration
right wow it could be aspiration is one
issue it could be that certain cells
have a greater tendency to take up lipid
nanoparticle and so those cells in
whatever tissue they exist in tend to be
the transcribers or the translators
random and not I think haphazardous
haphazard is definitely right whether
any of these other terms apply I don't
know probably not but
in any case
the problem is that in order if you take
the brochure and what it says about how
these vaccines are supposed to work and
you take it I like one of those
brochures
it's a doozy of a brochure but okay so
you've got these lipid nanoparticles
coding mrnas with a particular message
yep that um gets translated in the cells
and exported to the surface of the cells
where it's supposed to stick and at
least in the original version didn't
um but the problem is that the body
will when it sees a cell producing its
own your own antigens as your cells all
do and also producing a foreign antigen
that is a red flag that the cell has
been compromised by a virus in this case
it's a pseudovirus
one made in a laboratory but your body
doesn't have any way of understanding
what that would be the fact that was
made in the laboratory doesn't make it a
pseudovirus is that the fact that in
this case it's not the full virus it's
just a transcript no I'm going to call
it a pseudo-virus because what it is
horoscope E2 no or okay the the the VAC
the so-called the transfection agent the
lipid nanoparticle and the MRNA but the
reason it's a pseudovirus is not because
it was made in the lab which is what I
thought I heard you say
yep it's just the fact that it's a coat
that gets it taken up into cells that
then triggers those cells to produce its
proteins yes not their own
the body recognizes that as infection
there's only one rational thing to do
with a virally infected cell from the
point of view of the immune system that
is to kill it
killing cells can be not that big a deal
if they are in tissues that are uh well
positioned to replace them it has some
cost it accelerates aging somewhat it
reduces the capacity to repair somewhat
but probably very tolerably in some
tissues
I mean other tissues it's catastrophic
you do not want your heart cells
attacked by your immune system which
have come to understand them as virally
infected that is an insane thing to
allow to happen
now
here's the crazy thing about these
bivalent boosters
the Wuhan strain is as far as we know
extinct in the wild
for them to give you half a dose of
Wuhan
in order to give you half a dose of
updated
means that you are wasting half of the
cardiac risk for nothing and other
right half of the risk half of the risk
but the cardiac risk
very serious the risks of strokes and
clots and other things all of these
risks half of what you're getting from
this isn't liable to be valuable to you
because the Wuhan strain isn't
circulating yeah
so why would we put you to any extra
risk if if this was really about
boosting your immunity by updating what
they had given you already yeah right it
would make sense to just update you yeah
why would you give this crazy cocktail
that is out of date and it's half out of
date okay that's one thing what Robert
clued me into was what he was calling
imprinting I asked him is that the same
thing as original antigenic sin and he
said very closely related
um probably not worth drawing a
distinction but the idea is
when you
alert the immune system to a hazard with
something that functions in some way
like a vaccine and in this case these
transfection agents turn your cells into
a vaccine Factory so there is a vaccine
involved here it's not what they inject
you with it's you produce it yeah right
um but it's super elegant oh it's clever
so clever yeah but elegant is the wrong
word yeah it's clever yeah it's about as
elegant as a sledgehammer but
um
but when you have this mechanism where
you are alerting the immune system to
something enough to cause it to mistake
you for infected enough to mount a
response that is then useful when
challenged with the pathogen when you do
that
you are
tracking the immune system into an
understanding of what world it is in
and when you keep vaccinating or
triggering the production of a vaccine
in the same neighborhood what you're
doing is you're broadcasting a message
into your immune system that causes it
to become effectively obsessed
and this is an insane thing to do in
light of a world in which this a isn't
the only pathogen you face right
tracking your immune system so that it
sees covet and only covid is not a good
idea what's more you're creating an
environment in which you're pushing the
virus around evolutionarily so it's
changing rapidly because you keep you
know nudging it right
at the same time you're tracking the
immune system to focus narrowly this is
not a rational course of action so
anyway all I wanted to do was clarify a
there are a lot of bodies buried under
the word bivalent
right the fact that we are you know
using mice instead of people the fact
that we are using antibodies as proxies
for uh Effectiveness right the fact that
we haven't recognized the massive Hazard
that comes from the fundamental
mechanism even when this thing works
right when it works it's because it got
into your cells and it got them to
produce a foreign antigen we haven't
talked about the cumulative cost of the
tissue that you're burning up as you
keep getting more of these things and
your body keeps regarding some new
tissue as having been infected we
haven't talked about that and if it's
worth it if the cost benefit analysis
reflects it we would only know that from
having had that conversation rather than
forbidding that conversation yes so
anyway I thought that belonged there
because we keep hearing so much about
these bivalent vaccines and you know it
sounds like one more uh whiz-bang bit of
scientific cleverness when in fact it's
a whiz-bang bit of scientific
recklessness
or who is yes good uh recklessness yeah
I wouldn't say good but bad how's that
good on you nice nice uh analysis well
thank you yeah I was not yeah you
weren't congratulations
bivalent transfection agents no I was
not no no I was not it's a really
terrible band name isn't it trivalent
oh we'll get there
can't wait yeah
um Okay so we've been at it for a while
yeah
um I'm gonna I'm gonna actually save the
the UN women thing I'm gonna just I'm
gonna put that into a little for paying
subscribers Only Natural Selections this
upcoming week so
um if you want to find out how
ridiculous you want women is being
um you can find me there on Natural
Selections um
but
I did want to just return to one other
thing before we before we stop for the
week uh which was this uh woke
hypocrisies piece that I published this
week in Natural Selections in which one
of the things I was talking about
which we also talked about in our
private q a last week was why it seems
to be okay uh to dress up in what I'm
now calling Woman face uh either as a
you know drag or in its uh more
egregious form trans
um when it's a trans right rights
activist as opposed to you know someone
who is you know really deeply
genderphoric and absolutely needs this
in order to feel like they can live
their best life which is a very tiny
number of people
um whereas uh the world I would argue
correctly says actually blackface not so
cool uh and you know it's not culturally
appropriation as some have have said
it's really it's phenotypic mimicry and
it's generally phenotypic mimicry uh
with an eye towards
um mockery and that's what it's a
phenotypic mockery is what it is it's
what blackface is and frankly I would
argue so you know women face although
many would say oh it's not mockery well
you see these exaggerated makeup
especially on on drag queens and it
looks like it looks like mockery at
least it feels that way to myself and
many other women who see who see people
in Drag and in in trans outfits
um
I went looking uh I one of the places
one of the
regions of the internet I have not here
to for explored was what happens to the
interface of uh drag queens and
blackface
some dangerous clicks involved in that
investigation dangerous clicks and uh
interestingly I didn't find anything
super modern everything was from a few
years ago but there were a number of
these stories and I just want to you
know put out their one one of of them uh
in which uh let's see this is uh
well in in all of the cases there is
some drag queens who are shocked at the
racism one of their members in which you
know he a white man does a character as
a black woman and
um you know I don't find these
characters funny at all for all the
reasons but you know some people
apparently do
um but what's strange to me is the
outrage the complete lack of
self-awareness in which the drag queens
are saying things like and here's a
direct quote from one of these stories
the whole concept of blackface being an
art form or being entertainment to me it
doesn't make sense at all that anyone
would think it's okay
said Alfonso King who performs drag
under the name Jade Electra
the whole concept let's just change
blackface to Woman face the whole
concept of Woman face being an art
former being entertainment to me it
doesn't make sense at all that anyone
would think that's okay
now maybe the difference is that some
number of people who are doing drag as a
form of entertainment will say I'm
celebrating Womanhood
well it doesn't read that way to a lot
of us and I don't think almost anyone
who goes out in blackface thinks or
would even claim that they're
celebrating Blackness I think that that
is going to be one distinction that
people will make but it lives as a
inconsistency that I now can't unsee
that you have people who are so embedded
in what they're calling an art form of
adopting the the looks and the artifacts
of the opposite sex
and doing so without any regard for how
that will be regarded by the opposite
sex who can stand up and say you must be
fired you must stop doing that that's
not allowed when it's about adopting a
phenotypic indicator of a race that
they're not it is at the very least in
consistency I read it as hypocrisy and I
re I also read it as something that you
know other people have have tried to
engage this uh you know this whole
concept of trans racialism right like
you you can't be transracial
except that and I make this point in the
work hypocrisies piece you know sex is
actually real and ancient and binary and
for at least 500 million years and
probably closer to one to two billion
years we have been in a lineage that has
been reproducing sexually with two and
only two Sexes and every single human
being who is who is among your ancestors
has been either male or female that is
true whereas race to the extent that it
has biological reality is much more
muddled those those borders are muddled
there is no pure anything in race
because we are sexually reproducing like
I mean this is actually one of the weird
points here right like because we are
sexually reproducing and have been
forever basically yeah not quite but
almost forever there is no pure race
that's a fiction that that is the
fantasists uh you know who are racist
who would tell you that there is purity
of race so there may be people who are
all from you know Scotland and all of
their ancestors from time immemorial but
nowhere close to 500 million years have
been you know Scottish and there may be
people who are you know similarly
Lithuanian or you know whatever but
every single new person is the result of
sexual reproduction and therefore
there's no Purity there and so if
transracialism isn't a thing
transsexualism really is not
all right there's a bunch there yeah I
think there are a couple things that
need highlighting one I think you're the
point you're making can be well
encapsulated by saying can we is there a
meaningful distinction to be drawn
between a Minstrel show and a drag show
I heard Minstrel
um menstrual show not a thing thankfully
Minstrel show yeah and a drag show yeah
menstrual
Minstrel show there you go and a drag
show and I would argue
there are distinctions you could draw
but
those distinctions are subtle at best
and what they tell you is actually
you should sit down for this
um actually neither of these things can
be a Minstrel show and a drag show
put the shows aside you can't rule out
blackface right why because the
character of Roger needs to do a
Minstrel show at his daughter's wedding
right on Mad Men on Madden you drop the
lead there so you've got a character a
white man on the show Mad Men Who
behaving in a racist way the actor is
allowed to put on blackface to play the
character who is being abominable thank
you for filling in all of that yes
master is not actually sufficient to get
most people there right likewise yes
Monty Python has to be able
to um
do Preposterous caricatures of women
lumberjacks no it's not the Lumberjack
it is it's all of the characters where
the Monty Python dudes
um you know
he's not the Messiah he's a very naughty
boy that thing right is Brian's mother
right Brian's mother for example in the
Life of Brian yes right so the point is
that there's nothing offensive in my
opinion yes about the Monty Python thing
and in fact it is mocking itself in its
own way the ridiculous portrayals of
female are so
silly yes right that that's part of the
comedy
the importance of blackface to the
character of Roger in Mad Men in Mad Men
mind you
um the importance of that character's uh
cringy uh Minstrel show at his
daughter's wedding is fundamental to
the plot yeah so really does daughter's
wedding I believe so I don't I don't
remember that part but anyway it was but
anyway point is
in a civilized society right it is fine
to make a rule like uh blackface is not
cool because it isn't yeah right that
does not mean there there are no edge
cases in which you have to allow it
right or where it's important yes right
um and likewise last week we talked
about
um you know Victor Victoria
Mrs Doubtfire I believe we'll talk about
that in their private q a oh was that
private anyway so those those examples
plus money
plus Monty Python those examples all are
cases in which there's a very strong
defense to be made of something which in
another in another context uh
would be troubling
I don't know exactly what to think about
drag shows I don't know that they're
identical to Minstrel shows and that we
will come to understand that or not but
I I I think never haven't been to either
yeah that uh the people engaging in the
black face of the woman face will have
different stories to tell that the
minstrel shows which aren't a thing
anymore yeah
um from the let's call it the 1920s
uh had people donning blackface knowing
that they were proudly making fun of
black people and that drag shows in you
know 100 years later and it's not a fair
comparison because it's 100 years later
but that at this point anyway drag shows
um I think it is going to be the rare
drag performer who will say of course
I'm making fun of women that's not going
to be the cover story right so there's
there's an important distinction there
but one which you know but one which we
have to try to
um correct for the difference in time
between when they're happening I
actually think it's almost the opposite
thing that's that's bugging you and that
has you focused on this
I do think that a drag show
I've never been to one either yeah a
drag show from 30 years ago
involves men who do have a strong
affinity for
femaleness who do aspire to it in some
sense it's aragonophiles right many are
fair enough but the point is that's very
different than mocking
all right and I think what you're
responding to is that as trans activism
has become hostile to women right this
has gone from a weird aspiration it's a
nice fetish a niche fetish but
nonetheless a something that is desirous
enough of being woman that it will you
know Play Act Right to being a threat to
women in declaring that this is
synonymous with being a woman right and
that that is actually the thing is it's
gone and that Minstrel shows were never
that
they were never as far as I know they
were never what you were performing show
from 30 years ago would have been right
exactly and yeah that may be right yeah
and I there's one other distinction I
want to draw
for our entire lives people have often
equated racism and sexism and therefore
the fights against them right this was a
mistake they are not symmetrical right
you've got two different types of
Oppression and disadvantage right one of
them is more pernicious than the other
they may be both terribly frustrating
but
it makes perfect evolutionary sense
for one lineage
to oppress another lineage
to drive another lineage to Extinction
whatever perfect evolutionary sense
well-being and Abomination it's an
Abomination but the point is it is not
illogical it is immoral but not
illogical
this has never been what went on between
males and females because males and
females share a lineage and every
individual effectively is arbitrarily
cast into one of these roles at the
point the zygote has formed and you the
rest of the genes in the genome don't
know whether they're going to live out
this life male or female and so the
point is the idea that male genes gang
up on female genes doesn't make any
sense because most of the genes spend
half their time as each one so
male individuals will try to control the
behavior and placement of female
individuals as has happened forever but
male genes ganging up on female genes
except with regard to something like
genomic imprinting on the fetus where uh
just to you know do a little David Hague
style thing very very briefly here
in a situation in which a mother a
pregnant woman is pregnant with a man
who may not be the father of her future
children
she has an interest in having a child
who is as healthy as possible but also
retaining her ability to have future
children and so we have as humans a a
problem a trade-off where we want our
kids to be born as late as possible as
fully cooked as possible so they are
maximally likely to survive but we have
gigantic heads and for women to have
pelvises as wide as would be optimal for
the birth to be safe would make women
very very unstable basically and so
birth childbirth is not just painful but
quite dangerous precisely because
there's a trade-off between size of the
child's head at Birth and you know how
fully cooked it is and therefore How
likely it is to survive and so a woman
who is pregnant simultaneously wants
that child to survive but also wants to
be able to still be reproductively
capable for future children and so the
genes in the fetus that were inherited
from her some of them are more likely to
tend towards a slightly smaller head
size on birth
so that she is able to not just take
care of that child but future children
whereas and that's and those genes are
so-called imprinted
um so the the fetal the fetus has genes
that are imprinted from mother
um that um it inherited he or she
inherited from mother and those that are
paternally inherited that are um that
are imprinted from Dad I'm not sure I'm
saying that exactly the right way
imprinted from Dad but um the dad's
genes especially in a polygenous society
are more likely to drive the head of
that child to be larger on birth so that
the child is more fully formed on birth
but even in that case
the male who loves him and leaves them
yeah has an interest in that female
surviving to raise the offsprings it's
very unlikely to survive if she doesn't
so absolutely but but this is but I mean
this is not just theoretical work right
like hey let's demonstrate this is you
know work David Hague Harvard in the 90s
I think right and it's been you know
followed through with a lot more that
we're not going to go into now but
um it is known that genomic imprinting
it is true and that maternally imprinted
genes and paternally imprinted genes are
in disagreement in this one small way in
um with regard to for instance the
degree to which the child is is
um is fully cooked on birth they have a
limited not being the technical term
they have a limited disagreement and the
point in this context the point is that
disagreement is not limited between
lineages which we wrongly call races but
nonetheless yes the distinction between
race on Race oppression and
sex on sex oppression is no comparison
at all they're very different and the
fact is individual women may suffer from
the fact that power is very
asymmetrically distributed in
Civilization
less so but it has been very
asymmetrically distributed but there are
women at every strata right at every
level of well-being and
the distinction between that and what
happens in races is a major one so if
there is you know the argument here has
been there might be some distinction
between a Minstrel show and a drag show
but it's awfully hard to explain exactly
what it's based on and even this
fundamental difference between race and
sex oppression does not suggest an
obvious distinction other than the one
we've talked about where
um
a drag show
could be something other than mockery it
could be aspiration and I don't think
Minstrel shows ever are yes I agree
good
um well I'm sure we'll come back to this
topic at some point
um sex and race being through perennial
yeah perennial topics they are evergreen
uh and uh I will
I will get to why U.N women tweeting
that we should stop that's the targeting
of women journalists should stop was uh
while yes that's an admirable sentiment
it was an absurd thing for them to say
given the evidence in front of them I
will put that into Natural Selections
next week at some point uh in the
meantime we've got uh we're gonna take
about 15 minutes and we'll be back with
our live q a you can be asking questions
on that for the Q a at
darkhorsesubmissions.com we will start
as we always do with a question from our
Discord server so if you're on the
Discord server you have an ability to
pose a question that gets voted on that
we answer at the top of the Q a every
week
um maybe that's it
until we see you next time and we will
be here uh actually from our new
permanent temporary temporary permanent
Studio next week uh 12 30 uh Pacific
time Saturday
until then we get to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside buckle up
[Music]